Do you want to talk shit about our products?
That's cool too.
Oh,
you crazy fucks.
We're here with live.
Uh,
George Saint Pierre is here,
this episode of the podcast.
Oh,
you hear that?
That's me.
Steps of the podcast brought to you by [inaudible] dot com if you go to o n n I
t use the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 10% off any of the supplements.
We've got a lot of new stuff there if you haven't been there,
especially in the fitness department.
We have of course the new primal kettle bells that are kettle bells that with a
chimpanzee's face that looks like he's biting your Dick off.
That's what it looks like.
That's the look that a chimp makes right when he clamps down on your nutsack
crazy little evil animals.
Uh,
we also have weight vests and uh,
if you look at all this stuff,
it looks like armor.
It's not,
it looks like steel.
Macy's a weapon.
It's not okay.
Folks is just shit to work out with.
Uh,
and George St Pierre will tell you,
functional strength is where it's at,
right?
George Chin ups and Shit.
George's all into gymnastics and body weight exercises.
Every time I see this pull up bar it looks like a hacksaw like this is to use to
cut off your head of your enemy.
Yeah.
Underneath that too.
Boy You do the Chin ups for a Polo,
got her chops,
Zombie heads off.
We've got awesome all kinds of shit.
They're like,
oh Madison bells and um,
and uh,
lots of supplements to make your body and mind strong.
Matter of fact,
I just took four Alpha brains right before the show and I got a solid eight
hours sleep.
That shit's important,
right George?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
That's George Saint Pierre pitching respect when he says it's important,
it's important.
I did not get eight hours sleep.
I don't believe you.
I think I went to bed at seven.
Uh,
this episode is also brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is a one of the
newer sponsors of our podcast,
our podcast.
Is that what it is now?
It is when you're selling products,
right?
It's like a broadcast.
Um,
stamps.com is the way it's set up is a lot of times if you have a small business
and people sell out packages and shit,
you have to go to the post office and they have to wait all that stuff.
You have to wait in line.
It's a pain that Dick,
nobody enjoys it.
And The lady,
she doesn't want to see you walking up with your big stupid fucking bundle
packages that she has to weigh.
The whole thing takes a long ass time and there could be three or four people in
front of you and they're all doing the same thing.
You're there forever instead of that,
you can do it all from your computer if you buy any of those desk squad tee
shirts from desk squad.tv that Brian's cells,
that's exactly where they come from.
They're all this a stamps.com so you set it up so you weigh your stuff at your
place,
you print up your own little postal thing on it.
Yeah.
And there's paper or he gets printed right on the envelope.
It's a really fucking easy,
even Tom Segura does it also that we all do it.
Like if you listen to any podcasts and they have merchandise,
it's probably going through stamps.com,
because there's no,
there's no way in the road you'd want to do the post office.
Yeah,
that much.
And if you go to,
um,
there's a a little,
uh,
up in the upper right hand corner,
stamps.com.
You can see the,
there's a little microphone icon.
If you click on that and enter in the code named Jay are,
you will get the,
uh,
the offer that they're showing up there on the screen.
It's a $55 in postage,
postage,
coupons,
and free digital scale that you're not used.
You're not allowed to use to measure your weed.
Okay?
This is only for the post man.
You Fox,
uh,
go to stamps.com,
enter in the code name GRE and save yourself some money.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by hover.
If you,
uh,
if ever heard us talk about Tang on this show,
a hover is a owned by the same people that own Tang and it's a domain name
company and they have the same approach at Tongass,
you know,
things approaches,
trying to rip people off,
try to give people a good product at a good price and keep everybody happy and
make it easy and they,
and they put in things like free who is domain name,
um,
privacy,
which when you register a site like uh,
what was the one that you are the bridge to the last time already and my mouth
dig party in my mouth.com.
If you go to dig party in my mouth.com unless you Brian Red van,
if you're a normal dude with like a regular job,
you're like,
man,
I don't want to be associated with dig party in my mouth.com.
I would like to register this and privacy what with hover you can do that shit
for free because a,
they're not worried about all that.
They're trying to give you a fair product.
And if you go to hover.com,
forward slash Rogen,
uh,
you can save 10% off domain name registrations.
All right.
And if you do dig party in my mouth.com backslash Joe,
you're getting an extra deck.
Hey,
that's not true.
You fucking made that up.
Um,
that's it.
A Wednesday night,
uh,
at the ice house,
we have a big fat comedy show with Brian Red Band,
Bert Kreischer,
Tommy Segora,
Tony Hinchcliffe and me.
And it's 10:00 PM and it's 15 bucks and a,
it's like the best comics in La stopped by a lot of times.
It's like we've done them with like eight,
10 people there.
Now the ice house is awesome to them.
We're probably going to do a podcast with Burt,
uh,
earlier in the,
in the city.
Um,
but that's a 10:00 PM.
And then the other shows are May 3rd and fourth at the Sacramento punchline.
Yeah,
it's Brian,
Sam,
Tripoli and Tony Hinchcliffe.
And then May 5th at Cobb's in San Francisco too.
Awesome clubs too,
by the way.
All right.
Your Fox.
George Saint Pierre is here,
the contam welterweight champion in the world.
Bitches.
We're going to get down to it.
Play the music,
Brian.
Yeah,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Oh,
you cut out the Nick Dia as part.
Let's see what he did.
Very,
very smart.
There was a thing that Nick Diaz had a quote.
It's like,
you know,
train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
And I do not hate him.
Now if you folks it up just listening to this,
George Saint Pierre is our guests and he's a UFC welterweight champion of the
world.
Just recently defended his title against Nick Diaz.
Um,
does,
does you call it nick now it seems like you guys were complimentary after the
fight.
What am,
I don't know if he's cool with me.
I'm an got I.
I'm all right.
I'm cool with everybody.
That dude turns everything into a personal affair,
right?
Yes he does.
Does that ever get to you when guys should talk to you?
Cause you're like,
if people didn't know you all right,
if for the average person did not know what you do besides the look,
you know that you're physically strong,
they would never think that you're a fighter.
You're a very friendly guy.
You're very like easy to,
I've seen you interact with a lot of different people over many years.
You're very easygoing,
very,
very nice to get along with.
Yeah.
I don't want to be,
I don't want it to look like a fighter.
When he talked to me and let's say on the phone,
I want it to look like a normal human being.
Right?
Of course.
Yeah.
That's,
it may a little bit the impression that people would have some time.
Well,
you're,
you're not just a nice guy.
You'll like,
you're honest about your own vulnerabilities,
which I've always found fascinating.
Like you talk about what,
what makes you scared.
You talk about what you're worried about.
Like,
you know,
like even this nick dance,
what you like,
I am scared because I don't want to lose to this guy.
Like this is a lot of people who never admit that
and yeah.
But it may make you think and make you stronger to admit that you're scared
because you're not scared to say that you are scared.
Right.
Someone who doesn't admit it because he's scared to admit that he's scared,
scared of himself,
scare care of what people are gonna think about him.
I'm not scared what people going to think.
They have to see me as I as I am.
So I'm not scared to admit that I'm scared.
And it's almost like when you don't admit you're scared,
it's like you're praying,
you're protecting yourself from evolving because the only way you can ever be
realistic about a situation and get better at anything in life is you've got to
accurately address what's happening.
Sure.
100% with,
you know,
and there's some people that don't do that,
and I think that cuts them off from a certain amount of progress in life.
I think there's a certain,
there's,
there's like walls that you put up yourself because you're not willing to look
at your own failures
but sent,
you're not the,
you're not the honest with yourself.
So that's what it is.
I did a bit.
Yeah,
so admitting you're you're afraid is like so what?
Bitch?
That's it.
You know what?
As much as I'm afraid I'm going to make that walk that they have had,
did they have that?
They have it and I'm going to do it regardless and it sounds more crazy.
I wouldn't be more afraid of a guy that says,
I'm like,
who says I'm afraid,
but you know what I'm going to still do with and I don't care if I'm afraid
bring it,
I'll do it like this.
It sound crazy to me more than a guy said,
oh no,
no,
no.
I'm not afraid because this guy,
he's a light.
He's afraid to say that he's afraid.
He's like,
man,
you know what I mean?
To me like personally,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
The posturing and posing.
It's unnecessary.
Exactly.
But you are afraid of aliens though,
right?
Yeah.
My friend.
Does it turn,
you have like a,
a path mapped out in your house.
How to get out of the aliens show up?
No,
that's the rule.
I heard you have a plan because I know you like to use game plans had I know,
I know cat ready and I know Jujitsu,
so the alley and show up.
I put a triangle choke on him and I also have a cat that ammo so I Catana
Japanese get know.
So if they come I can slice them apart.
Wow.
You keep it stored in your house.
It's say it's a collection,
you know it's for me it's I have to to burn or bring any crazy bitches home.
I man,
it's a sword and crazy bitches.
I have this tax all on the side of my bed that I always forget is there and it
was like almost cut my finger off all the time.
And you should put down in the garage,
big sword slash meat cleaver that it's just
so do you really have a fear of aliens or is this just a bullshit rumor?
It what didn't you do a countdown show and you did a whole thing talking about
how you being scared of being abducted by aliens.
Yeah,
I'm scared.
I'm scared of a lot of thing,
you know?
I'll get,
I'll get into it.
I got,
I kept talking about it right now and yeah,
I'm talking about it right now.
One day I will get to come out and make a big thing about it,
but no,
right.
Hold on.
Hold on right now.
Yeah.
Have you ever had an experience with aliens?
I don't believe you.
I don't know.
You don't know.
You might have had an experience with my manager going to have a heart attack
right now.
My brother
never do or lead you down any path that's bad for your career.
Just as you said that it's good to be afraid.
It's also good to be honest about everything.
Even shit.
That sounds crazy.
None of it does a thing.
I'm on s I like,
look,
I'm on s I'm afraid,
but I don't have to tell everything on,
on the phobic.
It's true.
You don't,
but you know it's an alien because you're a smart guy.
Let me tell you,
you're a very smart guy.
You know.
You know how to dig,
dig into people's mind.
And as I like you,
I hate that about you because he put me on the spot right now.
But he's a very smart guy.
But now I know I gotta I gotta go too deep into this.
And if I was on an alien spacecraft and I had sex with an alien,
like I'm assuming you did,
I feel like I would just come out and talk about it.
I don't know why you would hold that back.
No,
but I mean,
something happened,
George.
I don't know.
It's either,
it's either I'm crazy or,
or,
uh,
maybe it really happened,
but I,
I hope that I'm crazy.
I don't think you're crazy.
I hope I am.
It could be pre crazy.
She didn't know.
Some people like some great mine and you know,
they had,
they had been hallucinating stuff or somebody bought our [inaudible] say magneto
depressed or some people are,
are,
uh,
OCD.
Some people that are there,
some people are dead and they're still,
they've been able to achieve great stuff on their life.
And also maybe I'm crazy when I was,
I don't know.
Are these experiences I can help you one way or these experiences happening at
night?
I am not sure.
I have not.
I'm not sure.
Have any of these
variances happened while you've been in the dream state or were you just been
dreaming or just asleep and you were
woken up?
I am not sure to that expert.
I don't know.
I don't remember anything.
But it was the worst at nighttime type things.
Was it nighttime when you think you might have had something happen to you?
Uh,
I can't say something happened to me.
I have no proof.
I just don't know.
What I'm going to tell you about is your brain produces a chemical while you're
sleeping,
but I've got it.
I'm going to tell you something and I'm going to be honest about it sometime.
Um,
I'm looking at the clock and it's like I wake up and I look at the cracker right
after I started and it's like the clock had events like a four hour or two
hours.
There's a time zone that I don't remember what happened.
It's called falling asleep.
I hope so.
What do you think you think you're getting snatched up and take it away for a
couple hours.
Maybe I fall asleep.
That's why I hoped.
That's why I hope or I can drive.
I can drive my car,
I can drive my car.
And then it already happened.
I drove,
I drove my car.
[inaudible] I dunno,
I drove my car in a normal day,
like going somewhere.
Then I look and this two hour pass and like two hour,
I would just pass like this.
Like maybe,
maybe I didn't see it.
Maybe I didn't.
I didn't,
I didn't.
I maybe I watched their tiny the wrong.
Like I watched my clock and I made a mistake myself most likely,
right?
Yes,
of course.
My hope.
I hope so.
Well that's very minor stuff.
That's very minor stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
but that could be,
you talked being tired because you push yourself and less stress.
It's exactly,
that's exactly what I hope.
So.
It's exactly what I hope so.
But you don't have any memories of great dudes putting fingers up your butt?
No,
I don't.
None of that.
I got it,
Joe,
where you're driving down the street,
like on the highway and you're just like kind of dazed out and you're like,
wait,
how long I've been,
I've,
I've been dazed out for like 20 minutes.
What have I been doing for 20 minutes?
Autopilot.
Yeah.
And then like,
you just realize like almost all of a sudden your home.
Yeah.
But,
um,
the,
the thing about being exhausted and sleep,
you know,
and having these experiences at night,
they,
there's a,
a chemical your brain makes that's,
uh,
one of the most powerful psychedelic drugs don't demand.
So one of the things they're trying to connect,
it's called DMT.
And one of the things they're trying to connect is,
um,
people having near death experiences and people that have had UFO alien
abduction type experiences and this chemical and that they can introduce this
chemical into the human body.
And these people have very similar experiences to what they had when they had a
Ufo encounter or when they had,
you know,
a white light near death experience counter.
It's most likely there's this chemical that's doing this.
So when people having these experiences,
they're very realistic and they do believe they're being taken aboard by,
you know,
a Ufo somewhere.
They might not be wrong,
but this is not a Ufo encounter.
Boyd's
and then that the firefighting or job,
right?
Object.
This the I encounter.
Are we talking about that?
If they've been taking a board,
this is,
this is different.
It's like,
hey,
it could be a third type and commentary.
There's many ways,
but this is different.
Yeah.
But I,
I you talk about me,
I don't have any,
I don't have any memory of such team,
but I think I had like,
I have,
like you say,
sometimes I fall,
I fall asleep,
then I wake up is the time pass.
And I'm like,
well,
it's like I just,
cause you're tired man.
Aliens.
Yeah,
no worried.
He like,
man,
maybe it's alien.
It's kind of what you do.
No,
it's because I am,
I felt like I didn't fall,
I didn't fall asleep and I'm not tired.
I'm wide awake,
awake,
but I fall asleep rag this,
I just Kinda,
I mean it's kind of weird these onto hard sparring days.
No,
no,
just a normal day.
Negative could happen everyday.
Just get a Gopro like a camera and just record yourself all the time.
That happens.
Watch it recorded for like eight hours at a time.
Some of them.
Yeah.
How long has this been going on?
Since I'm a kid.
Wow.
Wouldn't it be crazy if,
uh,
the aliens like manufactured you to be a mixed martial arts fighter?
They're like,
let's see if we could,
I'm sure if it would have happened,
I would have been much better than,
than,
than this.
Much better than this.
You're the fucking champion.
Yeah.
But if I would be at here,
the manufacturer,
I would it be superman,
you know?
Well,
they just don't want to get ridiculous with it.
It would be,
yeah,
it would be obviously can't turn a guy into what God damn superhero maybe didn't
manufacture on Anderson Silva.
Jon Jones.
Maybe they did the Aldo.
Maybe someone needs to talk to them about their sleep patterns.
Maybe they're falling asleep behind the wheel too and being sucked to board a
space ship for repairs.
Maybe they don't want to talk about it.
Maybe they don't say it,
but maybe they are.
I don't know.
I know I'm the print that and they,
I think it's funny though,
that that's maybe one subject,
but you,
uh,
you have,
you had a really hard time talking about that.
I do.
Cause it sounds crazy.
Yes.
And I know,
and I will talk about it one day.
I'm going to talk about my fear,
my,
all of that stuff and yeah.
Ah,
no,
I,
I don't get deep into this.
Yeah.
Maybe one day I'll,
I'll,
I'll talk about that.
It's not what you promised one day.
I promise.
One day.
What is the difference note tomorrow.
Didn't you see rocky three when Apollo creed says that the rocky Balboa,
or like you said,
may,
maybe,
maybe I will die one day.
Maybe I'll die it tomorrow.
I hope I touched wasn't nothing and that people,
oh.
And I'm like,
how did you say that it was that French?
I touched with nuts.
I touched the,
wouldn't let it happen,
you know?
Yeah.
It just let it go.
Just whatever information you've got,
spill it now.
But I don't know.
I'm doing my,
I'm doing my own research.
I'm researching on myself as I think you know,
you just told me he's a very interesting day chemical.
That buddy that's probably that I'm happy that I meet through today and you tell
that about me because I make me make me up.
You know?
It'll make you think like,
I think a lot of people think they're going crazy and it's not.
It's just your brain makes like a duck trucks.
It's true.
Your brain produces it and parts of your liver and your lungs,
they don't know why this stuff is in the body,
but it's,
it's a super potent psychedelic.
Your brain makes it,
it happens when you're sleeping.
So if like the speculation is that it happens during rem sleep.
I don't think they have the most accurate way of measuring it,
but they know it's in the body and they believe it's the,
the theory is that it comes out during periods of heavy stress or when your body
thinks it's going to die or in rem sleep and that those are the Times that you
have higher levels of this stuff in your neurochemical soup.
That's an interesting,
crazy,
why would you brain,
why would your brain produce an incredibly potent psychedelic drug?
So a lot of people that are having these nighttime experiences,
it could be just varying levels of this chemical that's a going around in your
brain,
but that doesn't mean that these experiences aren't real.
We don't know what the fuck sleeping is anyway.
I mean,
what is sleeping?
You shut your eyes,
you shut off,
you don't exist in this plane and your consciousness goes somewhere else.
Like literally you have no memory of a giant chunk of your day and we have no
problem with it and yet we don't connect it to any other realm or the,
the idea of there being other dimensions.
You go into another dimension when you go to sleep,
okay,
you do,
you just shut off.
You stop.
And for all intents and purposes,
you are in another dimension.
And if while you're in that other dimension,
your brain is being pumped with this psychedelic chemical that when you take it,
when you're sober makes you have these incredible experiences.
It only seems to,
it just seems like a normal thing to look into.
Like people should be looking into that.
Like,
what?
What is what is happening?
When you're sleeping,
you're asleep.
You go away.
And everybody's just so used to it.
They're like,
no big deal.
We just go away.
Just go away for eight hours a day.
You know,
everybody's scared to die and no one's scared to fall asleep.
You're,
you're just,
you're shutting off man.
He know you're going to be back.
So you're not worried,
but you're shutting off.
Whatever that is,
you know,
is just accepted.
If sleeping didn't exist,
it would be the craziest fucking thing.
If all of a sudden you told people that they had to shut off for eight hours a
night and just completely not be,
they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
I got to shut off.
They'll,
but yeah,
you're going to shut off for eight hours a night and you're not going to know
what's happening.
People can touch your balls while you're sleeping.
He loves no way of stopping them.
He's a lot of things that can happen.
I showed it as like you said,
we don't know.
We don't know.
We don't know what the fuck that is.
I could,
I could like,
you know what I can say?
It's not that I'm afraid to be crazy.
It's just I,
I can say whatever dad,
I won't and we don't know maybe.
You know what I mean?
We don't know.
We don't know the truth.
We'd have no idea.
Somebody might be stealing time from you.
They might be stealing time.
You're like,
this motherfucker's got to the true.
It is.
I feel like I had experience,
but they don't know what it is.
So for me to say it said yet or say it's a dead drug chemical you're talking
about,
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't tell right now.
I don't know what it is,
but I did,
I felt,
and I get good to have been an experience or not.
Maybe I felt maybe I'm crazy and it's the normal thing that everybody would
like.
Maybe I,
but right now I,
uh,
like,
I don't know.
It's too,
I'm making my own research too to found out about that.
How are you researching?
And I research a lot of stuff.
Uh,
they committed their reason things and uh,
go on the Internet now.
It's another thing that he just said to me.
I'm going to research that Maine by research on the room.
I maybe by research things that people that have,
I've tried because that lap lap sauce time that you don't remember,
they've been,
some people been hypnotized on the ad.
The bad,
the bad,
the,
you know what I mean?
Is that venture,
and I don't want to be an uptight.
Well,
that was very controversial.
You know the,
what's happening during hypnosis,
hypnotic regression.
It's very controversial because there's a lot of people that believe that you
can introduce fake memories and to a person while they're unconscious,
and then you could,
you know,
you,
you could steer the events in one way or another and introduced false memories.
It's not,
it's not very,
it's not very reliable.
I don't think so.
That's one of the big things about these people that have these crazy stories
from hypnotic regression.
Like what the fuck is really going on?
You know,
you don't know.
A lot of times people that are in therapy in the first place or a little wound,
Doris,
of course.
So it's that those are the type of people that you're,
you're dealing with.
You're hypnotizing them.
And then you're finding out about these nutty experiences with aliens.
Who knows what the fuck
you're really,
it so credit.
He's just the same.
You take a fish and they'll water.
Okay.
And that fisheries,
it isn't.
And then as that environment,
let's say a fisherman,
he grabbed a fish in the water,
it pulls it off the water,
look at him,
look at meg,
the official guy around and drop the fish back in the water.
The fish after is going to go back to his friend and he's going to tell it.
The other efficient man,
I build it out of the water in and it was,
the people were breeding area was another environment.
I saw a human being pulled,
you know,
like,
and men grabbing me,
I saw trees,
I saw a bird in the sky.
I saw,
I like,
Eh,
like I son,
I'm like,
I see a different thing in different universe.
And then you put it back.
The other official thing,
he's completely insane,
you know?
So maybe in a way we're all like fish and,
and maybe there is something and you said that when you see,
but another university or another or well or something and we don't know and
we're right next to it,
but we don't know.
And if that's what I'm doing,
research,
I want to see,
you know,
I,
when I grow as a human being,
fine,
what was the truth?
Even though I probably will never found out the truth and I want to get close
circles or,
and find my own research to see what,
what's happening,
you know,
and we're all in the same pattern.
You know,
you know what I think the problem with fine people wanting to find the truth is
there is no truth.
There are truths.
I think there is no one truth and everyone is like [inaudible] I hope to find
the truth.
Like what are you talking about?
It's not one thing.
There's truths,
there's a lot of information.
There's a lot of stuff.
And to call it the truth,
like to figure out the whole big thing.
It's almost impossible for our brains to it to grasp like an aunt doesn't know
what a cell phone tower is.
It's,
it's almost impossible for our brains to grasp the enormity of,
you know,
going from protons and cells and,
uh,
an animal and a planet and a galaxy in a universe,
in multiple universes.
And it's not too much with,
this was just no way you're going to be able to take all the things that are
going in all over the world and understand it all and understand the pieces that
it falls into.
It's not possible.
So this whole thing where it was like,
I'm going to,
you know,
hopefully I find the truth.
You will find truths.
It's,
you'll never find the truth cause you're a a monkey.
Well private,
nothing that we're not smart enough.
We're not that.
Yeah,
that sound,
what did you say?
We are,
we are,
we're being birthed into a whole new universe of information that's never
existed for any previous human beings.
And we're not designed for it.
We're not designed to process this,
were designed to figure out where the deer going or designed to figure out who
do you want to fuck.
We're designed to think this guy,
he's probably going to take over my village,
this con.
And that's how we're designed.
And then within the last 10,000 years,
that has become,
you know,
watching like space documentaries and getting on the Internet.
And if it's too much,
it's no,
there's no way.
There's no way.
You know exactly what's going on over the world.
You'll go crazy.
You don't have the time.
It will take a lot of time in and it's still yeah.
To acclimate.
I agree.
100.
What's up with that?
Have you heard of like a lot of these guys like Dan Hardee,
did this go into Peru and they take those Iowasca ceremonies?
Did you hear about that?
No.
You didn't hear about that?
Um,
Dan Hardee did it again.
Wait to get him on the podcast and talk to him about it.
But he said it changed his whole life.
And it's the same thing.
It's DMT.
It's these Amazon Indians.
They,
they make it in a,
a brew and the active ingredient is in this brew is DMT.
And they have the ceremonies and they all get together and they'll play music.
And this guy like blows tobacco smoke in your face and he'd drink this stuff and
an hour and 20 minutes later they enter into the spirit world,
have life changing visions,
the wildest physical manifestations of your imagination you could ever possibly
think of and dream of.
You can't even think about it.
You can't,
you can't even put into words.
And it's legal in Peru,
you know,
it's legal and parts of South America.
So people are going down there.
This Americans are going down there on a regular basis and having these shamanic
rituals,
life changing rituals,
and it's all based on the same thing that comes out of your brain when you're
dreaming.
Yeah.
Pretty nutty.
You could,
I could make you realize things I'd like just say,
learn about yourself,
you know?
Do you meditate?
I wouldn't not say meditate.
I would say visualizing.
Yes.
Yeah.
So it's specific tasks in mind.
Like,
like visualizing fight strategies,
fights,
visualizing what I want in my,
uh,
what,
you know,
where I want it to be.
In 20 years I've tried to visualize where I could be and what I want.
You know,
it could be about fight,
could be about uh,
anything.
Cause we have all the,
my training and one hour where I went,
I'm going to do and you know about everything could be in business,
you know,
it could be when I'm going to meet,
uh,
someone when I'm going to say or you know,
could be an easy thing.
Do you have very specific like goals,
like for your life?
Do you have written down?
Yes,
I do.
Do you write them down?
Yeah.
Have goals?
So I'm a,
I wrote it down some I don't,
but the,
I do,
I do have a specific goal.
I have goals from like everybody,
I have a bigger goal in this much bigger,
much bigger goal than you.
For example,
are you going to be president of the world?
None of it.
I want to be for if,
for example,
one of my goals is like,
like is to have a,
to be married,
have a wife with a,
at least five kids,
four or five kids minimum.
Wow.
When I have a lot of kids,
that's one of my goal.
That's my goal.
And that's,
I'm not there yet,
but it's one of my goals.
You know,
I don't think you're going to have a problem finding a nice lady.
Finalize Lady.
I can get along with that.
That's a,
well,
I think you better.
I've had a lot of kids look up in Canada,
Japan,
that's what you need to ask.
Don't be trying to get these American checks.
They'll get mouthy,
especially after you retire.
Oh,
lucky you all retired and shit game.
That's a little flaky.
Do you,
um,
do you have like a clear timeline as to when you're,
you're going to discontinue your fighting career?
No,
I don't.
I don't want,
I just,
uh,
I didn't,
I didn't blend this.
Now I'm focusing on my camera right now and uh,
wanted to be the best at what I do and I want to,
uh,
make the,
be the guy that made the difference in this park.
You know,
bringing the sport is UFC grow and be more mainstream everywhere.
Well,
you've already done that just by being who you are.
You know,
by your,
your personality.
You know,
your,
your ability to just be a normal guy who just so happens to be one of the
baddest motherfucker
cause on the planet.
Yeah.
But uh,
you know,
I just,
I it still is.
Lot Of,
I love to do it and some kind of treated it's illegal,
you know,
and on a
right,
sure.
There's still a lot of work to do as far as the spread of MMA,
not just some countries,
some states it's still illegal in New York state.
When I first started.
Yeah.
And while I'm from my country,
it was a Daigo and kind of doing,
you know,
they did,
they,
it wasn't that sanction and everything.
So this,
I'm happy,
at least where I live now it's,
it's good and it's very popular.
Yeah.
I watched your first fights,
man.
I watched you in the Tko organization.
Yeah.
I watch all those,
you know,
it's a,
I've always
been a big,
big fan of MMA and I think that it's,
it's so important that there's all these other organizations going on like,
you know,
like that,
that MFC up in Canada and it used to be strike force and you know,
now this Bella Tor is doing really well.
It's like so important to have a bunch of different outlets for guys to pursue
careers.
But up in Canada was just like that Tko organization.
Right.
And then a couple anymore.
Yeah,
it was pretty much I'll need t that TK when you guys fought in a ring.
Yeah.
It wasn't hearing back down.
What do you do some guys prefer the ring.
What do you prefer?
No,
the cage.
The cage.
Yeah.
The ring is,
it's not the environment,
uh,
the cage as better or I would read or do like,
add the cages perfect.
As circular,
like octagon or a circular cage or even better than entering.
That would be like a platform where it,
where there is no walls.
There is a like a
like align,
align.
No,
no,
you don't fall.
But there is a line and if you step across and I didn't put you,
they put you back but there was a line and then there was a,
I beg you it so you don't fall about this platform and
yeah,
I see what you're saying.
That's the Super League and it's a bit like wrestling assuming yeah.
Kind of similar.
Yeah,
exactly.
Then it wouldn't be good too.
Yeah,
that's not a bad idea.
It's just a space consideration.
Probably the exact ad on know for sure.
Exactly what want some Brock Lesnar do.
Just steamroll and someone write into the crowd.
It's true.
And I know that would be,
that wouldn't be a quarter but,
but something like that or you know,
I think they got,
you know,
the the cage.
It's pretty good.
Yeah,
no it's a good day surface.
Yeah.
The only objection that people have as fans and sometimes it makes the action a
little harder.
See Two there,
you know,
watching it at home,
it's perfect.
I'm sure they could make a,
I meant Ariel,
which is like a window that could see truet like a plastic window.
Turn it off racy and shit.
Every time dudes would be like that.
Daniel Cromey a frank Mir fight happened.
Sure.
The whole thing would be just grease.
You wouldn't be able to see shit cause they,
those guys pressed up against every spot on that cage.
Sure.
It's awesome girl.
I'm in May now and it can be like a carwash liquor at girl and the main car.
I'm sure there is.
There's a lot of things I would've changed at this point.
First of all the time.
There's no time,
no round.
I think he's,
I think seriously.
I believe it's stupid.
The wrong one.
I see.
Was the best mountain.
Let them fight,
you know,
15 minutes or maybe 25 minutes for the championship.
No.
Around.
And why did that round,
why we tried to be like boxing,
you know,
or not boxers.
They did.
They did the round to be like boxing to be accepted as a sport.
It would probably be a lot more finishes.
It wasn't,
no.
Yeah of course.
100% no round.
You know,
and I got this,
this is ridiculous.
I mean I like it.
Me,
me,
me.
It's a receipt.
Do you think it's possible that the UFC would you,
would you,
would you fight someone like that 100% to arrange that?
Like as a particular rule,
like maybe the UFC could do it in Russia or somewhere where they're gangster
about it.
Yeah,
I would,
I would rather like,
I would rather fight it.
A rule like this.
I think it would be more honest like it who's that better than a man at that
fight that could have happened in pride.
They did that and pride right with this isn't hoists Gracie have a 90 minute
match with Sakharova.
But I think that was like,
even then it was like that.
That's when they used to be the real thing,
you know,
back in the day.
That's why I have so much respect for these guy is a Coleman Dan Severn cause he
had a pioneer,
you know.
Oh yeah.
The no,
no time limit.
I roll word.
Yeah.
This crazy glasses.
Joseph know who else have Joe?
Sam became like a Fred ocdish jail gang rape.
Oh my God.
Really?
Yeah.
Joe Sando is a part of a gang rape I,
yes,
sir.
Yes.
Yeah.
Apparently they didn't know what they arrested him for something else and got
his DNA and connecting it to a gang rape fall years by,
yeah.
I'm wondering what happened to the,
like somebody at a guy like I roll hour,
I think he got it.
Is that Canadian?
When I was a bunch of you guys,
I wasn't happy,
you know,
it's Kinda guy.
I was like,
yeah,
let's kick ass.
You know everybody through that crazy cart wheel kick.
Yeah.
On Steve Genom.
That was a,
that was a good fight,
you know?
Yeah.
It was good man.
How about that box?
Sorry,
Marissa.
And with white gloves.
Yeah.
What was the Jimmerson Art Jimmerson.
What was that about me?
Probably.
Maybe he had a hurt hand or something.
No,
I think he was thinking more like he's going to grab it.
Went in and swing with it.
No,
no,
and I don't know guy who knows to go to with Irvine,
but it was awesome.
It was that real thing.
It was,
it was that time were,
I literally watched the fight back in and then taught someone could die.
[inaudible] needed to have so much courage back in the day to step into the
octagon much more than nowadays.
Nowadays.
You know,
I can before it's no weight class,
nothing.
And who has known unknown.
I remember I fight like a Norris,
uh,
against that Pat Smith and that guy had that day.
You know what?
Like,
like a blood everywhere before they stopped that fight.
They UCF a towel flying and he still didn't stop that fight.
I'm like the,
this is a one time use.
This is the,
the guys that pioneer,
you know,
these guys,
they were a real tough guy.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
There was no referee stopping.
Yeah,
no referee,
you know,
round.
No.
At Lake Commission and no awake glass.
No with this.
No Dad,
no way.
Lights were fights get stopped quickly.
Does that Piss you off?
Why didn't,
you know,
it's to protect the,
uh,
you know,
at the referee can make a mistake sometime.
And it pissed me off yet.
Sad to see it when his a mistake done.
I think they,
they tried to be the best they could be.
But like the,
I believe the round,
I don't,
I don't think grown is good idea.
That's my open year round.
It's a good idea.
Yeah.
What about gloves?
Some people think there should be no gloves.
Some people think Nia guy and elbow guy and kick a guy.
Like why are they have covers on your knuckles?
That's true.
It could be an option but no glove.
But they would be a lot of broken him.
But that probably they would fight different migration.
I,
I wrote stuff that they used to hit a lot with the,
smashed it down,
you know.
Well if you,
you know,
she wants the old boss Rutan days and pancreas,
he figured out that he could throw punches
with,
he pulls his hand way back.
So instead of like slapping and like karate chop style,
he was throwing punches but he was doing with his palm.
Yeah.
But the thing is we wouldn't fight that same way.
We would fight now,
preserve our buddy like,
and I like it when I fucked in the ass.
I wasn't,
it wasn't turtle Bush and I was punching like if I were to be bare hand,
I would hit with my palm.
You know what I mean?
I wouldn't get that same way.
I would have probably be broke my hand or I never had my hand broken.
You know what I'm at.
I'm lucky,
you know,
but uh,
different,
different way.
It would make it better also for the,
all the grappling aspect of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and wrestling is I would be
better.
It would be more realistic.
I mean,
I don't really understand why they have a pat on the gloves.
I think it's a 100% I don't know if you don't have pads on your shins and your
kicking people in the face like come on.
That's crazy.
Like you're going to pad little knuckles and yeah,
you can cut people more,
but it also breaks your hand more.
It's just,
it's if you want to,
if this sport,
if you're trying to have it be realistic,
it's almost like bad to allow people to wear gloves because it allows them to
tee off and punches hard as they can without worrying about breaking their hands
100%.
It's true.
And I,
you know,
I,
you could break your hand,
but you know,
when you hit that guy with a good bunch on and their Dra,
you know,
at bare knuckle I don't think it will break your hand,
just doing karate,
you know,
Kevin cushion,
they,
you know,
well people are also um,
punch much harder of course because the tape and I don't think it's there.
The Grad I think is that they,
the holder risk.
So there was no movement than there is at everything.
All the impact makes it hard or is definitely,
that's why I believe,
yeah,
I think the hand wrap definitely aids the person who's punching.
But you also would be really cognizant of only punching with the first two
knuckles,
you know,
cause in boxing,
you know your toe,
you taught to punch and concentrate on those knuckles button.
Real reality.
A lot of times when you throw in combinations,
you're hitting them with all parts of your hand.
Whereas you're taught in karate,
the idea of a punching,
you know,
like a mock Mara over and over and over again.
It's a tough,
and these two knuckles Jack Dempsey says is that third Nicole the third note.
Yes.
He was punished with that Turret Nakota and it was no Starbucks cup power.
Yeah,
he could punch very hard.
Just I'm so he says is that third I call called because he said that I like him
enough that buddy is better with at third knuckle.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
So maybe I wouldn't never argue with Jack Dempsey,
but for most people believe that it's the first time I can cut,
right.
The same thing they teach.
But Jack Dempsey strangely says the third Nicola in that book,
he says that that guy was a fucking savage,
Huh?
Yeah.
And he was like,
watch those old old school fights and he would find dude's much bigger than him.
He was only at about a buck 90 and he was like one 96 or something like that
when he was the heavyweight champion.
He was fucking up those.
You know what?
I might be wrong.
I think actually Jack Dempsey was even lighter than that.
I think Jack Dempsey,
hold on a second.
Let me pull it up.
I don't even
think he was 196 rocky Marciano,
which has really Sarah?
No,
was one 75 yeah.
What the fuck man?
This certain dudes like that,
that chicks just can hit so fucking hard.
Yeah,
but they're all,
but it was not as big as well,
you know.
Now we're like months that I looked at Klitschko,
you know,
it's crazy,
you know?
Yeah.
It doesn't say his weight
on his Wikipedia says is a,
he was six foot,
not sandal or Dempsey.
It.
Monsanto was like one seven one one 75 one then one 80
Marsianno was one 85
mass general was,
I remember I read it was a one 80 none.
Nothing.
I don't think he was.
Dempsey was one 92 that's crazy.
Yeah.
It's like my size.
It's my size fighting the every white guy like Brock Lesnar over these shoots.
But they do,
they have those little tiny ass gloves back then.
True.
They just a little,
a little cover over the knuckles.
Very little padding at all and it was probably just like a little horse hair in
there as well.
Mild.
Wow.
Do you pay attention to like a old videos of like a old fights?
Do you ever watch like a old boxing matches and see like what guys like Dempsey
had to go through?
What guys like Jack Johnson had?
I wish a lot of stuff,
you know,
like I what I've been watching and the Internet,
recent recent days,
a lot of carry carry stuff everyday.
I really intriguing.
Really?
Yeah,
like dad at that point,
get ready guys.
It's very underrated.
I get like a,
a lot of good,
very good fighters.
They,
they come from that and I think it translate to him and made her very well.
Absolutely.
And Marsha was one 88 apparently.
Um,
the,
the ability to move in and out like really quickly as my best ever fought.
You fought in point tournaments before?
I did,
yeah.
Very frustrated.
I'm from Kyokushin karate.
It's not that same seminar.
I did point get ready before.
Yeah.
I find only a few point karate tournaments,
but uh,
I found them,
I'm,
I fought some fault one really high level guy and he was like,
he wins a lot of those point tournaments.
It was so different from taekwondo being like continuous fighting to this being
like stop,
you know,
it's like,
and it was really hard to fight that way if you're not used to it.
And I would just imagine that the guy who's really good at lunging in and out
like that.
Yeah.
If you could teach them all the other aspects of MMA,
there'll be a big one.
That's what I use for my,
I take it out on the shoot that people saw is your wrestling.
It has nothing to do with my wrestling and I was saying is that once I get that
leg I finish that they go,
but what I'll do,
I get in and that was because of karate before like no way guy right there,
you know,
and scarcity.
That allowed me to cut the distance and take,
take the people down.
I have a very good single to the boat or the very good Dubbo and a very good
penetration is because of my leg.
The way I do and this timing I get is from the karate.
Wow.
It's I wrestling too,
but karate primary because before I start wrestling it was karate guy pure and
I,
I just,
I he mates myself well to wrestling
and wrestling for especially for the mixed martial art.
Why does,
that's really interesting because I've always said that one,
you are the best things about you as the your ability to close the distance.
Yeah.
It's got read to you.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
totally makes sense.
Yeah.
My footwork pattern and everything is from karate.
Is this what I get it from springing in like that,
you know,
the ability to cover that distance,
that's a huge advantage covered in the sand and to not get hit.
This is very important.
Right?
Yeah.
And that is one of the cornerstones of those tournament's.
And that style,
did you um,
have a hard time when you made the transition to more Thai and MMA style?
It today,
today even my kicks are more like karate guy.
You know,
I don't,
I do more tie,
but I might kick,
you know,
it's like printed inside.
It's hard to say like you're a taekwondo guy,
you'll can kick butt,
you will stay taekwondo.
Like,
no,
it's fine too.
You know,
it's the best.
Like I believe it was the best spending back at you.
You have the best spinning back kick I ever seen in my entire life.
You know,
they're from taekwondo,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And is your background and you tried to change your technique of your spending
back keg,
it will be the worst thing you could do.
You know what I mean?
So I tried to learn to have stuff to Marzano,
but I don't try to change my,
my thing,
you know,
one.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
I um,
I still incorporate a lot of those techniques,
but I do more just regular more time now than anything else because I think all
those techniques like the spinning back kick and we'll kick for a guy like you
that has like a strong karate background or a guy who picks things up really
quickly,
that's,
you know,
those,
those are good techniques to learn.
But like for every day use,
it's hard to pull those things off unless you're doing it on a regular basis.
Like they become normal when you're fighting and Taco no tournaments and
everybody's doing it,
you're doing it every day.
But in MMA there's so many other fucking things like to,
to have the,
the type of leg dexterity that you see,
like the top level talk when no guys have,
it's be so hard to have that along with wrestling along with boxing,
along with Jujitsu,
like how do you manage like all your different skill sets?
Do you have like a,
like a 20% of your time goes to this?
30% goes to that like no,
no,
no.
It depends on the like fuck that.
Like I'll give you an example right now.
Um,
last week I was doing for the movie captain America,
that filming.
Then now I'm doing the interview,
but every day I find the time I go to Freddy Roach,
work on my boxing and this bird of my like this time on my box,
same pretty much.
And when I'm going to go to New York for example,
because I have to go to New York for a Dobro,
the book Promo and said I'm going to do my digits,
would John Donne error,
I'm going to be doing Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
When I go back and my child,
I mixed up everything,
you know,
but when I go to different places,
I go,
uh,
you know,
I do my,
my like,
uh,
specific things.
And this is in between fights,
so you don't have to scheduled.
So now
you just in the skill development phases it is.
Yeah.
And that's where my training is fun because I,
I,
I trained for myself to get better and I try stuff.
I acknowledge you see me if I go roller with my friend,
like it is like heading me,
I wrote,
I try stuff that I would maybe not have the,
the guts to try it normal dying because it's risky.
So,
so I'd try it.
Oh,
I get that bad.
You know,
I ate that but,
and I laugh,
who cares like that,
but I don't,
I don't care her sometime at that pay,
sometime I get that.
Right.
But when I trained for a training camp,
no,
I traded for performance so I have to perform.
I cannot be beaten and trainee is always,
my confidence will be effect.
So I tried to perform.
So that's where my training is not as fun as it is now.
Right.
Yeah.
The ability to loosen up in training is very important when you're in the
learning phase,
right?
Yes.
That's how you develop new techniques.
And there's,
there is an ego issue too,
like with guys who,
uh,
are not that good at Jujitsu.
Like you see it a lot like maybe like strikers,
they don't want to roll because they don't like getting tapped
stupid as it,
it doesn't mean anything.
You tap,
it doesn't mean you're not as good as the other guy.
That's mean you play that game and you just got to cut that none of it.
So what you know,
so when I got the tap all the time,
I don't give a damn.
You know,
it's a fascinating aspect of Jujitsu though.
That doesn't exist in other martial arts.
You know,
like if he was kickbox and spar a guy,
it's not as it,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
you don't want to be knocked out.
But I mean is it would be that same thing in a way.
Let's say you,
you're a Jujitsu guy and you do kick by someone,
that guy,
but that guy will not knock y'all.
You will,
it will.
Let's say we'll do a combo that he will be like,
you will know and I owe that right hand and would have knocked me out if you
know it's something you're Jitsu.
Oh I would tap,
I'd always,
he would have break my arm.
It's same thing.
We,
we don't hurt each other.
You can allow it to go further without hurting then and kickboxing for example
where it's tracking it can be brain damage.
Yeah.
That's the hardest is that,
or I should ask you is that the hardest place to find guys that are comfortable
with training with is in striking.
So you know that they're not trying to knock you out.
You know,
you like every day in the gym is in a war.
Fred,
the Ag and it too is I have many times people try to hurt me and I tried to with
her,
you know,
and I have no choice.
You know,
I've been,
you know,
and when I first,
no,
it's different because of the nut RBT APP.
I can find place how I can go and I mean training,
it's training,
you know,
we still go hard.
There is a smart way to train.
Of course,
I don't try to hurt myself when I train and tried to hurt the people,
you know.
But of course I say I'm training for a fight before a fight and we spar hard.
If the guy you see,
you heard the guy,
you let them breed,
you know,
don't go for the finish.
But the thing is for example kicked today,
who control that kicked today?
Things like that,
you know,
we don't do needs today.
The hell Buddhist stuff like that.
We don't do that.
That and this is important.
I have a good training partner like that,
you know,
cause sometimes we turn it with someone who was crazy.
He's gonna you're,
you're getting ready for a fight.
It's a lot of money on the table.
He's going to cut.
Yeah.
Cut you or say like is things like that you don't need you to make a name for
himself.
So now when I'm,
people ask me,
hey,
what are you going to go train in my gym?
And like this is because sometime I had,
because I go train in the gym,
they know who I am and I'm George Saint Pierre.
And they go,
oh,
I'm going to try to hurt him to make a name for myself.
And that sucks.
You know,
that's,
I don't like it.
So that very careful with where I trained now that's the bad side of it because
they let other people tried to take him out.
They can make that name,
you know,
and I don't like it.
You know,
I'm,
I like to try it with different trade partner and you guys and,
but now I have to be careful to do it.
I cannot do it,
you know,
I have to,
have to know where I'm going with Dell.
The guy tells me,
Oh,
this guy kind of go with him.
He's,
he's good,
you know,
and I don't care what that got tapped out or it'd be dominated.
That's not what I care is care of,
being hurt,
you know,
or android and I'd be able to,
to work,
you know,
it's a lot of money when I have a fight after counseled.
It's,
sorry.
Yeah,
there's always accidental injuries,
but there's the injuries where,
you know,
a guy's trying to hurt you because he's trying to,
that's gotta be really annoying.
Wow.
There was guys that I'll do you say they,
they always hurt people.
So,
no,
I didn't mean it,
but like why it always happened to you,
man.
Why?
I always happen to,
I've got it in the gym and Marcelo is like,
when I bring my training partner air for Lex,
I bring a guys to train,
uh,
from like my last training camp,
bring guys to train,
uh,
for my training camp to mimic an IG of the,
as I told these guys,
I listened,
there was this guy,
this guy,
you're not going to train with him because he's like,
and they're all like,
whoa.
It,
why,
why?
It's like,
because when every time someone trained with you is yapping on injuries,
I,
yeah,
but I don't mean,
and as I,
you don't mean it,
but it's still happening,
man.
There's like [inaudible],
that's all you are a man.
I've seen guys kicked out a gym for that,
of cars of course.
But some guys,
it's intentional.
So guy,
it's not intentional,
but even if it's not intentional,
you don't want to take the chance to do with,
you know what I mean?
I don't want hurt people when we meet,
want to try and find me.
I got that hour it and training.
It could have happened accidentally once and are very rare.
It's very rare.
I heard people,
you know,
very,
very rare.
I couldn't,
if I wanted to,
I could,
but I don't hear,
I don't hurt.
I don't want to hear it here.
Heard the people,
you know they're trained.
Yes,
of course.
Of course.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a couple guys I know that it's just people who just won't train with
this.
He just,
they're just
walk away hurt because you know what,
the minute you're going to turn with them,
it's going to be a fight.
You know it's going to be like I really fight and I and I'm and you know,
I don't,
I fight yet and I'm paid to fight and I don't want to hurt myself in real life,
you know,
and I don't want to have to,
to hurt so I don't want to put myself in this situation.
Great camp now though man you got,
you're going to so many different great guys.
John,
Donna,
her who's one of the most underrated or underappreciated Jiu Jitsu coaches in
MMA in the world.
Really you know it with you.
If you look at all the different guys that get famous for coke and Jujitsu talks
a lot of people about John Donner and they all said the same thing.
Like that guy's a bad motherfucker.
Super Smart,
brilliant in the corner.
Like I love the advice he gives.
He's always on point.
Direct,
accurate.
I scribed the most,
I would say legs,
brilliant educated man I ever met in my,
in my life.
You know,
he's brilliant.
That's a lot of people don't know.
You know,
I believe he was a philosophy major.
Yeah,
he is that he is a phd in philosophy.
It used to teach philosophy in Columbia University
before you drop everything and dedicated his life to shit.
So when he was,
I got night and that hip hop,
oh my God,
hip hop clubs,
can you believe it?
And apparently he was like big on like weightlifting back then it was my buddy
and then he starts doing Jujitsu and fell in love with it.
See that's amazing.
Yeah.
So you go to him for you to Jitsu and Henzel as well,
right?
You could go to hens Zos yes,
I go through a it.
That's what a lot of gems.
Yeah.
But I travel.
It's a good thing because I have,
it's places that no matter what,
like I come to la often for business stuff,
but when I come to la,
I have the place where I can train in La.
You know,
I'm very happy I faced while I can trade in New York.
I go to New York a lot and,
and,
and Montreal of course,
if hounds and Pat Pat,
he frowns,
you know,
and,
and it's,
it's important.
And you know,
sorry,
I started going everywhere I go out,
back,
go home,
where I'm,
I can go with came there,
get better.
That was hilarious when you brought that a French dude with you on the ultimate
fighter and he showed up,
hammered.
What is his name again?
Josh on Charlotte's got Buskey.
Yeah,
he's very good point.
That guy,
very famous Moitai a kickboxer and he would be partying all night and show up to
the gym with one of them club cups,
plastic cups and it was fucking alcohol in it.
He's out of his mind.
Shows up.
He was drunk and high from the party.
Like you haven't slept for more than like 36 hours and know that this flight to
Paris then I thought I made the training.
When you arrive I made on purpose.
I,
I made arrogant as a training for him to come teach the afternoon class,
the late afternoon,
not that morning class because I say I was thinking all he's going to sleep.
No,
Yara from Paris the night before,
went out all night wet and then an after party went and uh,
after,
after party.
And I arrived straight to training,
didn't even go to his hotel room and training,
kick everyone's ass.
Boy.
Everybody was like,
what the hell is
this?
And even when they,
when he left,
because he stayed for like a week when he left the producer of the,
of the ultimate fighter,
he came to see me,
George,
we need to get this guy.
We need to keep this guy here.
Oh,
that's good TV.
You know?
I was like,
no,
he's leaving.
Yes.
To go back.
It was making me look bad.
No know.
It was like,
it was like giving,
I know,
and he's not an imposing looking guy was amazing.
When you look at him,
he's not like a scary looking,
but he doesn't
know anything about them.
Memory.
That's the thing.
He has no idea.
It was chocolate.
There was under,
you had no idea.
You came in the room and he sold those pictures.
Like,
who's these guys are,
you know,
like,
it was all of those like
famous Muay Thai guy,
but mom doesn't know anything about it.
Yeah.
He fights Tai's like yes,
he fights in lumpiness stadium
and if I black out again,
he slides,
it could work out with the spinning elbow in their head.
Then you know,
like he does not fight.
But you took that fight on their short notice like,
like a few days notice.
And he was underweight.
It was the ad to gain weight for the,
there were the way class right away glass.
He doesn't care.
He has like,
he has like courage like crazy.
Wow.
It's weird cause you look at the guy you would never think that guy,
that fighter.
It's amazing.
Like all right,
sorry.
We're surround by a lot of character and the boxing is much more famous in
Europe than it is in America.
Isn't that true?
I believe the level is higher in Europe.
Yeah.
Apparently the glory though,
they're going to start to bring glory to someone.
Um,
I think they're going to bring it to see,
frank shamrock said they're going to bring it to CBS sports.
Uh,
I dunno what channel that is,
you know,
which,
I know I think cvs has like a bunch of different channels that they own,
but if they start Aaron,
those like high level,
you know like a gold con Saki and Daniel Geeta and all these like high level
heavyweight guys got some wild shit to watch.
It's true.
It,
it's a,
it's gotta to be interesting,
you know,
bringing that to here.
Yeah.
It's so funny how like the difference in just like a pure straight up kickboxing
match,
you know,
when guys have no worries about being taken down,
and when people say,
oh like the level of kickboxing and MMA is not as high as the level of kickbox
different distance.
Yeah.
Every friend you cannot compare different stance.
I list over,
we didn't get knocked out by a,
the Tonio big footsteps of a daze.
I K one champion.
You've got it guys.
It's not the same thing.
It's not that same thing.
I mean it's easy to adapt when you are at a higher level k one guy to adapt to
MMA timing.
But there's,
the timing is different.
I think Allister had some issues going and stuff like,
cause they could be too,
like,
I don't know the inside of it,
but I've just,
it's got a testosterone issue.
Ah,
it's got low testosterone because yeah,
he,
you know,
he'd,
he tested high for testosterone.
Like he had taken something.
Okay.
Now he has low testosterone.
That,
I mean,
like,
it's just an,
like an example,
I don't know,
dad they'd behind behind goes or what look
like.
He had a lot of energy and big foot Silva waited until he got tired and just
beat the shit out of them.
That was a,
that was a brutal knockout too.
I remember,
I was surprised to see that.
I was like,
oh my God,
I was not expecting this big foot.
Silver looked awesome.
That was an amazing combination,
man.
I mean,
you know,
whether,
uh,
Alster was hurt or not,
the combination he leveled them with was devastating.
You know,
just,
I mean,
he was key.
It was like,
it was a lot like,
like remember Phil Baroni and Dave Manet,
remember that knockout or Phil Baroni had David [inaudible] up against the cage
that was violent.
It was not quite as like,
oh,
he hit him like four times before Monet can even drop.
That was bad.
Yeah.
And baroni could fucking hit and the just teeing off on him.
It literally is keeping them standing with his punches.
This big foot one wasn't quite as devastating as that,
but it was number.
Yeah,
man.
It was like bouncing on.
They felt like bang,
Bang,
Bang.
It was like the greatest punching,
not highlight reel knockout ever that brony Manet fights.
It's true.
It was bad.
It was bad at some of the those knock out of your Washer,
like,
Ooh.
Yeah.
When,
um,
when you first lost your title to Matt Serra,
there was the first time that Matt,
Matt,
Matt said,
right.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's true.
When you lost your title Matt Serra and you know,
and maths or a stop to,
you know,
that was,
was that like,
that had to be like the most devastating loss of your career,
right?
It was,
but I learned something vulnerable that allowed me to survive to Carlos condit.
What was that?
When I get hit by Matt Serra,
the First Punch,
he,
he uh,
I make me very dizzy and I was so proud that pride,
it's a good thing,
but it could be a bad thing.
I was so proud.
I'm,
I'm a very proper,
so,
so I got,
I got,
uh,
when we're both just say an English Womble I got,
I got Wabo and instead of back off and say,
Oh,
I'm going to go back to my sense,
wait,
that,
I go back to my Calibra before we attacking,
I got Webo and I got so angry.
I was like,
I can't believe this guy because back in the day it was like five to one,
10 to one,
the odds,
I was like,
I can't believe I get wobble by a guy like this.
And I looked like back in the day.
Like I was saying,
I was angry that I got wobble.
I was proud gay first time I ever happened in my life,
so I want it to give it back to him as fast as I can,
but that's already hit very hard was I was,
I didn't have any caliber them.
I got a website with one shot.
Then I tried to jump back into a war with him into a slug fest with him while I
was wobbled annual hasn't,
so I got punched,
I boom,
boom,
boom.
Then he started the tee off on me and then I fall down and I had thought about
it.
I know it was completely,
I would,
I,
if I would have to keep going I would be like,
you know I,
you know,
I just stop and things.
God,
the referee stopped.
But what happened with Carlos condit the same situation.
I got kicked in the head then.
Then instead of telling,
oh I need to give it back to him,
I followed him around.
I said,
you know what?
Yes,
I got caught.
Then relax.
Now it's time to re defense,
catch up your bread,
catch up,
your your senses,
Bang,
Bang.
I focused on my defense,
my shield grows,
everything,
every opportunity as to hurt me.
And then I came back after,
so I step into my,
my uh,
my ego a little bit,
tried to accept the fight.
I got hit,
relax,
and then I came back later.
That's a little bit of it.
That's the experience that I gained from that loss with Matt Serra that allowed
me to survive.
Carlos condit.
Interesting.
Because Carlos Condit we dropped me with that,
that,
that kick.
I,
the first time he cut me,
I want bold,
but I didn't drop like I was,
I was on my feet,
but I tried to get back right into a slug fest with him instead of backing up,
tried to use my work,
get back to my senses.
And that's what happened.
I got,
got the,
you know,
sometimes you learn during your loss and that's what happened to me.
Matt Serra by beating me,
he helped me become a better martial artist.
You know
the uh,
the what,
what had you in more trouble?
The Punch by Matt,
Sarah or the kickbox condoms.
My Dad did kick I believe with condit was like harder,
was a bigger kick.
The first punish if you look punches of Sarah finished me because it was many
punches and that I took many punch before I fall in a and when I fall I was too
late.
I was completely the,
the,
the these at the DC,
you know,
but,
but I,
I should have,
when I got bunched and wobble because,
and that's already,
he had very hub and I never seen that much coming.
I should have stepped back and or old him or go for it,
you know,
instead of trying to slug fest with him and gone condit when I got,
I got dropped,
I said to him,
I says,
how,
okay,
like don't go back until,
because I couldn't go back and try to go a single or go back up right away.
I said,
okay,
use the guard off,
pop up close and close everything and,
and you know the,
because I was dizzy a little bit to come there.
You know,
I didn't see that coming at all.
I follow his buddy and his kid come on their side and on the temple.
He Bro,
he,
he damaged my uh,
temple artery by the way.
It was a hard kick man.
Yeah,
it looked like a hard,
that's what do I spit all after and I get it fixed.
You know,
you have to go in 10 minutes.
What's going on here?
Is that why you guys were having a fucking conversation?
What,
what is it that's going on?
You know,
have another interview man.
What kind of other interview?
You've got some boring ass bullshit is what you got.
What do you got to do a,
it's either a prs stuff for the book,
I guess.
Ah,
the book PR stuff.
Um,
so everybody wants,
and I need to go train to joy.
Yeah.
Where are you going to trend tonight at Freddie Roach?
Tell anybody,
man,
I'm going to go watch it.
I'd have this security that the nerves do you,
um,
like now that you,
you,
you just beat Diaz.
There's a lot of people that are coming up in the hundred 70 pound division.
Of course Johnny Hendricks is the,
the big name and Jake Ellenberger and all these different guys.
Do you at one point in time there's been a lot of talk,
uh,
at one point in time of you guys getting together and you and Anderson Silva
meeting maybe at a catch weight or something like that and fighting in a suit.
A super superfly
yeah.
Is that question everybody asks me.
They asked me that even before I came back from my injury.
You know,
they want me like I need to do stuff at my division before.
I think because it's new,
it has moved now,
so I don't,
I know somebody is fighting a quiz.
Wait,
white men,
but not nursing stuff is very big.
You know,
he's a one is two 30 pounds,
you know,
it's very big guy walking around.
You're big and I'm one 90 pounds.
Right.
And if he's a lot of way different.
So it,
you know,
if this fight that happened and one day we're gonna have to decide what weight
class and you know everything but this is,
you know,
and I tried to see figure out what's going to happen and what the,
wait could I send everything he says he can make one 70 back if you want.
Maximum one seven yeah.
Wait one and you come once in a knee is fine.
Do you think that's possible?
He was fighting back in the day in Japan at one 68 that was a long time ago.
But he was,
he was over 25 years old.
Wow.
So you think he,
if he just did it slowly over a long time?
Yeah.
You've ever seen the biggest weight cut I did or anybody that you've ever seen
anybody do?
I don't do much bay.
A lot of car.
It would be easier for me to go fight at one 55 then finding one 85 I would be
more at my weight actually,
that I,
the one for,
there's guy won 55 they walk around one 90 like me.
Yes.
I've seen them.
Yeah,
because they think I'm big because I have a large frame,
but I don't want to have a,
another big guy at very,
I'm not tick tick,
but eh,
you know,
I,
uh,
we'll see the site.
Like I know why he's fighting and women and like Andrix is freaking out.
He wanted to fight me a little,
you know,
we'll see.
You know,
what's going to happen in the future?
What do you think is next?
Is it going to be the Hendricks fight that's not going be car Andrix you know,
that's a big fine.
Yeah.
But the thing is every like is always going to be a guy that people say,
oh,
this guy got that beat you,
it's after Rick Warren and who knows what's gonna happen.
Yeah,
no,
it's good.
Fine.
It's a,
it's a fight that a lot of people want to see you.
You have a very talent stack division,
you know,
you at the top and look at how many a great contenders are at one 70
yeah,
no,
no.
It said it's a tough,
it's a very tough division though.
What's it like walking around with that kind of stress?
I mean you got like a whole line of trained killers that want to get to the
champ,
you know,
is that a difficult thing to manage
and that's stress.
I tried to take one fight at a time,
you know,
and a focus on the one guy that I have no choice.
I cannot split myself enough,
you know?
And for me that has to fight where close to each other and my second fight that
training can,
and it was brutal,
like in no way that I didn't have mental break.
Now I needed to take a little break,
meant it to come back stronger after because I always thought,
well I will get third what I do,
I will not be as good as I could.
I could be,
you know,
but you still train,
you still constantly.
But I trained for fun.
I don't try to for performance,
which is different.
Like I explained earlier,
I trade for myself and having a good time.
It's fun.
Now while you're doing this,
do you keep up with the Jujitsu at all or do you just do your boxing?
None of them.
I do Jujitsu too.
I like how many hours a day do you train?
I depend.
Like now I'm going to have only maybe one hour and a half.
I'm going to try not Freddie and,
and that's it.
And then I,
you know,
it depend my schedule number.
Yeah.
I train twice a week,
twice,
twice a day,
uh,
to treat,
treat three hour maybe total like two training of an hour and a half.
The training itself is maybe 40,
45 minutes for 30 minutes.
The training itself,
but that talking that this,
the dad that changing that shout down and hour and a half,
um,
now when you,
are you still doing gymnastics?
Yes,
I do.
How am I,
how often do you do that?
Once,
twice a week now.
And you think that's like a really responsible,
a lot
of like,
uh,
any track and field?
I did check it.
I run the check,
had a track door like sprints and jumps and 60 60 hundreds and four hundreds and
um,
you feel like that's the best kind of a exercise for frame and may if I would
have to start all over at GAM because back in the day used to train like an
idiot.
I was doing buddy bolder and watching movies like you know rocky and all this,
you know.
Oh and Jacco van Damme aren't all,
I thought that was the thing back in the 90s for my generation.
That was the thing back in the day where I'm from Canada and mix of martial art
and buddy building was the best mix of it would be you would your like you say a
bad ass,
you know what you say that then in the after we discovered at butterball,
dirt is not suited for,
you know,
it makes my trade,
it's better like do like I was doing more like a strength conditioning kind of
stuff,
but then I found out after that strength conditioning it was bitter and on a
picnic thing I think is better.
Does gymnastics.
I think I tried a few joints as well.
Yes,
track and field and gymnastics.
If I wouldn't have to do it,
that's how I would George.
That's how I would have to go back in time.
I would have to tell myself that George,
stop all that bloody building stuff that you're doing.
It's better to do gymnastic.
Yeah,
and a track and field.
Is that because you were already a fairly physically strong guy and you're
pretty strong from a wrestling as well,
but if I'm very strong when I arrest,
oh,
when I,
when?
When I grabbed someone,
I can that strength,
but they,
if I lift weights,
I'm not very strong.
I benched like wet to play,
to play the NAF maximum.
I'll have very strong bench press before.
Like my God,
you're not very strongly.
I gave,
I'm not strong at lifting weight.
When I was at,
when I was a kid,
I remember I was in school in secondary school and everybody,
the thing was to have a big chest,
you know,
every guy.
I wanted to have a big chess.
So I remember for years I used to do bench,
breasts,
flies,
Dumbbell,
and man,
I never had it.
Chess and my is and never had it.
I try so hard to train for it and never had volume right
here and,
and you know it's genetic man is,
that's the way it is.
So I said,
you know what?
You know,
I'm not gonna do it,
man.
I'm going to do for gym.
Like I give up on it.
I gave up my,
I have big legs,
big,
big butts,
big cat cock.
I'm going to say it,
but you know what I mean?
I,
I don't,
I don't have chess man.
I tried to work,
but it's done.
One of these things that,
you know,
I give up on it,
man.
I gave up plants do with Tommy Morrison did get breast implants.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of ways that I can use to have chess,
you know?
Have you seen that at the time he Morrison breast implants?
No,
I don't remember telling me.
Morrison,
the boxer they got out of the,
at the aids that day.
Yes.
Yes he has.
He has a disease.
Yes.
This is,
yeah,
I heard,
I heard that he also got breast implants.
I really,
yeah.
Pull that up Ryan.
Pull it up.
Tell me more.
So breasts,
implants.
Why?
Why am I doing this?
Okay,
here's why folks,
cause if there's a guy out there that's thinking about getting breast implants
and I can talk about of it,
I got to do my job.
He got to see this.
Take a look at this fucking picture.
This is Tommy Morrison.
He has a pull it up.
Yeah,
you want hit the switch?
Is this it?
Yes.
Look at that.
Oh man,
that's not good,
Huh?
Oh Man.
That's not that good man.
That's hilarious.
Wow.
That's,
yeah,
don't do that.
That's what I'm saying.
Folks.
Anybody to anybody.
Please listen to me.
Is there an unauthorized biography of you as well?
Yes,
there is.
I don't know.
It is.
It's sad.
He called up my mom.
You know,
my parents are very nice people.
they,
you,
they from countryside.
They always very respectful to everybody.
And this guy up,
Ronnie,
he called up my mom and my dad,
my dad,
who is a old ice go,
oh Yo,
Yo Yo,
you answer all their questions.
And I told my friends,
I stopped answering question that people call like this man because he's,
you know,
they're a little bit,
it's a little bit native.
They don't know what this,
this,
this thing.
So I said he just stopped talking to people.
You don't know about that.
Like asshole just wrote a book based in Yes,
yes he did.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a bad book.
It,
he only talk about my fights.
He basically described but my fight,
you don't say anything person or he doesn't know me.
He doesn't know.
Right.
Yeah.
So that's not a real unauthorized,
no,
no.
Real one.
The real one is the way the fight it's available on Amazon.
You can go by right now it's available in bookstores.
Can,
uh,
yeah,
you can get it on a kindle.
You can get it on audible.com.
Can you get it on audible?
Are you talking it?
It's me.
Yeah,
it's you doing it,
you read are doing.
I started doing it when I,
when I,
uh,
had my ACL surgery.
Ah,
that's where I started writing down stuff and,
but I didn't wrote all the words myself.
It's an English.
I know,
right?
It's made with someone I needed like a,
so you don't write it in English at all?
You just speak it?
I write English,
but I,
I would,
you know,
I would not write a book in English because it has been made in English first,
then in French.
So it's,
it's,
his name is just thinking sleep was a friend of mine who wrote it.
We wrote a damn book far for me,
but I,
you took stuff that I say and I had in my notes stuff that I write myself in
French.
He's,
he's,
he speak both languages by,
he switched it to the book.
Oh,
he's,
so you switched into English.
It's an a,
it's not a biography.
It's not about that MMA boy,
it's not a book for him.
I mean it's booked for margin rolled through,
you know,
what's it all about?
It's about my w the tactic that I use to be,
to start where I come from and to be world champion.
I find myself goals and uh,
a drizzle of reputation and I keep doing everyday and that's how,
you know.
So that's what the book is about.
Yeah,
it's more philosophical stuff.
Oh well it's more philosophical book.
It has nothing to do with MMA.
You talk about them and me,
but it's like people that like it normally is people because it's not as been
written by an MMA guy.
The guy were written,
he doesn't know nothing about MMA.
Even they may me people don't they,
it might be to see the terms I it because it emit,
you know,
sometime little miss [inaudible] car wreck and the future that would
misunderstood.
But,
but he's is a book about a philosophy and the mindset of,
of someone where I come from,
ally became successful from my experience.
Well George,
you're a bad motherfucker.
You're a cool guy.
It's always a great to talk to you.
Thank you.
I'm,
I'm glad to be a friend.
And it was a w one of the coolest things in my life is being able to teach you a
pastoral attorney sidekick,
and the fact that you would even listen to me when I tell you that I had a good
one.
I'm going to do it enough.
I'd want that from Msu.
I brought,
I'm not comfortable enough.
Fab.
We're going to do sooner.
Tighten it up,
man.
Let me,
let me give you some drills,
drills for it that can,
uh,
they can definitely help you out,
help you increase accuracy and we'll do it some more.
We'll train tomorrow if I serve and love you,
buddy.
Thank you.
Thank you very much my friend,
and best of luck to you in the future.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's the end of this abbreviated episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Thanks to hover a go to hover.com forward slash Rogen get 10% off your domain
name registrations.
Thanks to stamps.com enter in the code word,
J r e and the microphone in the upper right hand corner and save yourself some
sheckles son.
Uh,
for any information on,
uh,
Brian's upcoming comedy shows.
Go to desk,
squad.tv and a occluding podcasts that you can get only on iTunes on the dead
squat test squad labeled like,
um,
uh,
Ryan Kelly's muffs said,
and,
uh,
Kevin Pereira is pointless.
It's,
uh,
also the desk squad,
a ice cold ice house chronicles,
which we do on a regular basis and we probably will do it tomorrow night.
You want to do one tomorrow?
Sure.
We're gonna do one tomorrow night.
You dirty bitches.
Oh,
tomorrow night we'll see you guys at the a world famous Ice House Comedy Club in
Pasadena with Tommy Segora,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Bert Kreischer,
boolean red band,
and myself and a,
until then,
we love you.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay.